I just jump in right here where I made
music moment Alaska and Jeremy hello
little amethyst journey we are appealing
at if the aliens came down from space
would they be me and take me away this
is a little bit of a left turn from the
Alaska music we've heard in the past
yeah what does this mean for the future
of solo Alaska music I mean I see it as
like just another another side of it so
it's like it's like that crystal thing
it's like you look at it from a
different side and the light answer two
different ways so this is very like this
is really different but then that gives
solo Alaska almost more permission to to
be even like stupider and be more alert
so like I don't you know that's not it's
not going anywhere
[Music]
is there a future for the triple-a girls
at all or is that chapter closed
that's support me okay talk to Courtney
no we're like we're all like doing our
different things right now so I don't
know I want to wait and I want to wait
like ten years and then be like okay
we're bringing it back or bring it back
the act literally cornea bringing her
back yeah bring it back Jax I mean that
sounds that's what girl groups do every
like 10 years reunion tour yeah reunion
performance okay help me close this bar
bus driver wig girl oh I know you did
not would you have a street appointments
the nicest we all did love what Willam
and shangela and a star is born
oh my god I know why did you go in and
read for that to be a part of that they
my mom's gonna be stuff my mom's right
over there she's gonna be so mad at me
but they wanted they were originally
casting it as celebrities let celebrity
impersonators who inspired Ally and so
the drag queens at the bar were like
Barbra Streisand and like Tina Turner
and like Judy Garland and Marilyn Monroe
or something like that and so like they
asked me I didn't know what it was for
but they asked me like oh can you do
Barbra Streisand and I was like girl
this is the name of the best Barbra
Streisand's out there so go to them I'm
not gonna like I can't I don't know how
to do Barbra Streisand so I was like
that's not I can't do that okay for me
did you know anybody on your season that
was going in detox was on the same
flight so we lose something with
laughing yeah race chasers you guys just
launched season two of the podcast yeah
new new season new promo picture rich
but that means that you are getting
closer and closer to your own respective
seasons of that show how are you guys
going to handle those I don't know but
that's what everyone's excited about
though
so we're like working we're getting
there y'all we're I'm I don't know I
don't know how we're gonna do it but I
love it because we have access to all
the girls so we can like call literally
call them on the phone and be like so
what went down with this girl so like I
can't I can't wait till we get to our
seasons that'll be very exciting to to
hear all that the real information from
behind the scenes and then we know
all-stars for is coming yes we know it's
confirmed that it is the names that are
out there are not confirmed but is there
a queen you'd love to see compete again
shangela give her another take give her
another take um I think shangela was
fantastic I mean I would love to see
someone I
I mean india ferrah I think is is really
fierce and good at drag who else on
giant na jaaye know we need more season
one girls coming back and showing what
they've done Jade Sotomayor also I mean
like um yeah yeah okay those are some
names that I haven't heard tossed around
in a while so those are interesting to
me yeah I would love to see I would love
to see that
you
[Music]